Tổng thống mê đưa nân trâm thông báo, ám tối hâm là vình trăm đối với sê tại hạn chung và hạn nặng nhập khâu.
Có hiểu lực tương ngày 1, 1 tháng 1 năm, anh yển không trọng hàm làm.
Chính xác này được cho là nhằm cùng cố năng lực sẵn xuất trúng lức và giảm xức vụ thuộc và nhập khâu.
Chúng tôi cạnh ngành tốt nghiệp ô tô Mỹ đang chữ xức cách cạnh trình lớn tự nước ngoài.
Tuy nhiên, giới phần tích nhận định.
Bí tám thui có thể khiến Chí phi mô sê tăng, tất động chực kép đến ngày vận tài,
lính vật vận chuyển hơn bẩn bị phần trăm tổng khối lượng hạn hóa nội địa của Mỹ.
Bởi hơn 2 triệu lâu động làm việc trong anh bất kì biến động sá nào,
cũng có thể làm sợ nướng chi phía logistic và giả thư dụng.
Môn nè khâu sê tải lớn nhất của Mỹ hiện gồm,
Mê hiểu cầu, cán thưa ra, nhật bản, đất và phần nàn.
Chúng không cạnh kinh tế thuần cầu đáng phục của chấm.
Đợp thế này, gồm vào xinh tình được dự vợo sẽ tất cả đỏ mạnh tự kả trối của mướng khu vực bắt Mỹ.